Roosevelt summoned to the White House
the three coaches from the major
football programs and he says to them
football is on trial and we must save
the sport
i am nick gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with John Jay Miller
who is a national correspondent for
national review as well as the director
of the journalism program at Hillsdale
College and the author most recently of
the big scrum how Teddy Roosevelt's a
football how did he save college
football there's a lot of talk about
violence in football today with
concussions and the long-term health
effects of head injuries but the problem
of brutality in football today is
nothing on what it was like a century
ago in 1905 18 people died playing
football this is from the big time
college level all the way down to San
lot because of this a proto progressive
prohibition movement rises up to ban the
sport it's led by Charles Elliott the
president of Harvard the Nation magazine
muckraking journalist they view football
as a blood sport they think it is it is
gladiatorial combat in a Roman
amphitheatre and no place in modern
American life so they want to outlaw
football and it took President Theodore
Roosevelt to stop them so he steps in
and what what are the steps that he
takes well first of all Roosevelt
becomes a big football fan in 1876 when
he goes to his first game he's an 18
year old freshman at Harvard he gets on
a train goes down to New Haven he
watches the second ever game between
Harvard and Yale falls in love with the
sport he doesn't view it merely as good
entertainment although it's that he also
comes to see football and rough sports
like it as important to as a
socialization rough sports are good for
boys they help turn boys into men and
they helped create the kinds of men who
can lead America forward and this is
pulling off I mean he is famously
Roosevelt was famously a sickly child
and asthmatic maybe a neurasthenic or
whatever so this all fits into his kind
of right warrior right well and he comes
to believe in the value of physical
fitness and exercising and he thinks is
just good for people then his own
experience taught him that you can
possibly overcome asthma that mayor name
may not be true but he believed it and
so he his most famous speech ever was
the strenuous life lead a vigorous life
and that that that that that's the way
to live so he thinks football
contributes to this so it's a social
good for him so this
prohibition movement springs up to ban
the sport he loves that is not just mere
entertainment but actually social good
in 1905 this movement is gaining steam
editorials being written about the evils
of football and why it needs to be done
away with so Roosevelt summoned to the
White House the three coaches from the
major football programs Harvard Yale and
Princeton and he says to them football
is on trial and we must save the sport
he encourages them to have some reforms
he doesn't tell them exactly what to do
but that winner they go back to their
campuses they create the organization
that becomes the NCAA and pass a bunch
of rule changes the most important of
which is the creation of the forward
pass because up until that point that
were quarterbacks but there weren't rut
wide receivers you couldn't throw the
ball downfield and at that moment
football not only began to solve this
problem of violence by spreading play
out around the field rather than having
massive piles up of guys so I mean less
of a scrum and more of a spread off well
it turned what was essentially a rugby
style game into the distinctively
American sport that we enjoy today so we
flash forward you know a century later
college football is a huge industry
schools spend tons of money on it
contrary to most analyses USA Today
found that even at major schools such as
Ohio State that general revenue funds
from college students are going to the
athletic departments to subsidize
big-time college sports is it time for
college sports to be spun off from the
universities and turned into semi
professional leagues or something where
they're actually paying their own
freight rather than taking revenue away
from students and you know actual
education there's a good case to be made
that's true one of the things I learned
in researching this book is that is that
money was a big issue from the start and
financial corruption Yale in the 1890s
was was looking for ringers to join the
football team they were they were
perfectly willing to lower their
academic standards in order to bring in
guys who could score touchdowns so this
problem has been there from the very
start a big-time college football it has
been it has been a problem that has been
unsolved for a long long time
and it'll it'll remain with us I think
for your becoming the head of the the
director of Hillsdale colleges
journalism program talk a little bit
about how Hills de will actually not be
stressing journalism classes as much as
having your majors get a get a college
degree and something else exactly so
there are journalism classes but nobody
majors in journalism at Hillsdale you
have two major an actual academic
subject and learn history or english or
biology or whatever which is which is a
real strength because because those are
real academic disciplines journalism is
not journalism is woodshop you go in and
you put out a newspaper and you learn it
by doing it so there are students though
they'll get a little bit of journalism
in the classroom but you know how to
write a lead and what is the inverted
pyramid paragraph scheme and all that
but we will teach them how to put out
newspapers how to create content to fill
it and you ask about the future of media
the media will always need content
creators so we'll be training them how
to do that and trying to find new ways
to communicate well an old-fashioned
paper publication but we also have a
website and will be tweeting and
twerking and to demon all that well I
want to thank John Miller who is the
author of the big scrum how Teddy
Roosevelt's a football for talking with
us today a good look at Hillsdale and
beyond thanks John
you